Here's an RGBA texel value that is not pre-multiplied. Let's called it
unmultiplied. If we pre-multiply the RGB value by the alpha value, we get this
result. If we undo this multiplication, we get the unmultiplied RGBA values
back. All unmultiplied RGBA values can be converted to premultiplied RGBA
values and then back again to unmultiplied if needed. Precision could be lost
in converting back and forth like this, but otherwise it's always valid when
starting with an unmultiplied value. However, you can start with a
premultiplied RGBA value that cannot be properly converted and stored as an
unmultiplied RGBA, and so could not have come from unmultiplied values. The
question to you is, which premultiplied texels below come from valid
unmultiplied numbers. Valid means that all four values of the unmulitplied RGBA
are between 0 and 1 inclusive. The order of values below is RGBA as usual. My
advice is to think about what the premultiplied RGBA value is representing, if
you have any concerns about whether it can be converted back to an unmultiplied
value.